i got an email yesterday from slug
about the topic
of the left needing better arguments
when it comes to the topic of abortion
in other words the the left needs to be
better prepared
and better articulate the absurdity of
the right-wing position on abortion
rights and the obvious logic
of the left-wing position on abortion
rights in the united states and slug
pointed out in this email to me which
which was really great thoughtful email
that one of the main topics of
discussion in the abortion rights debate
in the united states at least
between just people who engage in in the
topic
when does life begin is this major topic
of discussion
is it a person or not
exactly when does life begin
what about personhood and then we say
i would i would argue accurately so well
if it's a person five weeks after
conception
then should there be child support for
that person at five weeks after
conception should there be citizenship
even if it if the fetus is the child of
an undocumented immigrant if it's a
person at five weeks
then maybe there should be citizenship
and if so that means you can't deport
a pregnant woman
regardless of her immigration status
because she has a real person in the woo
so you know there's all these
conversations and it's fine
but slug argues
that it's a waste of time
in the sense that at the end of the day
it really is a philosophical question
and in a sense a religious question or a
philosophical question informed by
religion the anti-choice right isn't
going to accept arguments from doctors
anyway imagine that imagine that doctors
could say hey you know what uh it's a
person after 27 weeks
the right's not going to accept that
anyway so maybe it's sort of a futile
effort to debate that and at the end of
the day
we don't make law on philosophical or
religious beliefs or at least we
shouldn't
although we know that fundamentally
christianity is at the core of much of
anti-abortion sentiment in the united
states fine so slug's idea is the right
says abortion is murder so the state can
legislate around abortion on the basis
that it's like murder but really we
should be saying no no no abortion is
more like organ or tissue donation this
is the idea and in fact before the fetus
is viable outside the womb
it's really a lot like organ and tissue
donation in terms of our legal framework
around it we don't force people ever to
give away an organ or to donate blood or
to donate plasma or plasma as trump used
to call it or bone marrow we don't do
that even in some cases and there are
many of them where someone needs blood
or bone marrow or an organ to survive
right there there's a life on the line
we never legislate that you have to do
this thing you have to donate bone
marrow or whatever the case may be and
in fact people regularly require those
donations to survive and many people
don't get them and they die people die
on waiting lists all the time
that's tragic
but we don't force anyone to go under
the knife and donate a kidney or get
hooked up to uh um
you know it's not an iv it's
to get hooked up to have a blood or
plasma or whatever taken
and we never charge people who don't do
those things with murder nor
manslaughter it's never even part of the
conversation you've got to register as
an organ donor to even be contacted
corpses can't even be harvested for
anything without written permission
right
if forcing organ or tissue or blood
donation is considered too invasive for
anyone to ever talk about doing it by
law
how is forcing a woman to lend her
uterus for a fetus to develop
acceptable since it's even more of an
invasion of privacy and a violation of
bodily autonomy than donating blood or
plasma or a kidney the fetus uses the
mother's body for nine months
it causes permanent changes it risks
health issues it potentially you can
even die through pregnancy not to
mention obviously the responsibility
being placed on the mother for 18 plus
years 25 plus years 35 plus years some
of some other millennials will
understand so the idea here is from slug
maybe the left should stop arguing about
when life begins
and start forcing the anti-choicers to
admit they think the fetus deserves more
rights than everyone else and women
deserve less bodily autonomy than
everyone else it's still sort of an
in-process idea that a viewer sent to me
i wanted to share it with you
send me your thoughts as to whether you
think this might be a better angle or a
useful angle and again remember
it's not so much about convincing
the anti-choice right wingers it's about
framing the argument
in terms that aren't subject to just
philosophy i mean we don't force organ
donation we just don't and lives do
depend on it
we don't force tissue donation blood
donation whatever and lives do depend on
it if we don't do that
the invasion of forcing a woman to carry
a pregnancy to term is far more
significant and so how do we justify
that doesn't seem to make any sense let
me know what you think we'll do a follow
up you can find me on twitter at
deepakman and i want to mention again
and we are seeing
what's happening with our mailing list
is out of this world on monday i
mentioned that on memorial day we're
going to do a one-day membership special
we're going to blow out memberships to
finish out may we may run out of
memberships quite frankly
at a major discount we're doing it on a
holiday because my lawyer would never
allow me to do this on a business day he
would say no no no no don't this is too
cheap our accountant would say david
this is terrible business manager would
say it's too big of a discount so i'm
doing this on a federal holiday while
they're all sleeping and not paying
attention
monday memorial day get on our mailing
list at davidpakman.com
you'll get an email
telling you
here's the discount code
it's good today only
become a member and you'll get all the
perks that come with membership the
bonus show of course which alex jones
hates oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad he's
furious about it uh the commercial free
audio feed of the show the commercial
free video feed of the show priority
access during viewer town halls the next
of which i'll be announcing soon so all
you have to do today
is get on the mailing list at
davidpakman.com
and then you'll hear from us on memorial
day